now since these are the sporting purists
from the Porsche family its GTS models
test driver Klaus needs fit says there's
a newcomer to the 911 series the targa
GTS you might ask why
well some people want a car that differs
from the basic model one that's
sporty-er more powerful and the target
GTS also has a different suspension for
better road handling and where's the
best place to test it on a racetrack and
that's where Klaus is on the Ascari race
track in southern Spain in despondent of
that and taketh collie as for a former
racing driver Klaus is eager to test the
GTS and the Sport Plus version with the
electronic stability system turned off
he takes the target --top' model to its
limits
closes first impressions the engine has
real bite 430 horsepower
no one needs that much but here on a
racetrack it enables him to drive very
fast laps Klaus says the engine responds
as soon as you press the gas pedal the
car takes off like a rocket the target
GTS has a six cylinder 316 kilowatt
boxer engine that launches it from 0 to
100 kilometers an hour and 4.3 seconds
hard to top but power like that calls
for a suspension to match Klaus says the
chassis is a centimeter closer to the
road than the standard Targa enabling it
to take curves faster the cars
aerodynamics hope would hug the road a
higher rear spoiler also helps it take
curves faster and that's what Klaus will
do now
now come the rear swings out of it says
Klaus back what fun
as far as the target GTS is design goes
Porsche knows exactly what pleases
sports car fans like matte black 20-inch
wheel rims with central locking the roll
bar is a target trademark
the steering-wheel synthetic suede
finish pampers the drivers hands and in
its GTS models Porsche provides a treat
for sports car fans ears
Rula Porsche engineer says the target
GTS has a choice events for the exhaust
including one that's under aatul that
boosts engine performance but also adds
to the sound
guns inside of our vehicle tester likes
that you can drive this target with the
roof down though you sit in a relatively
enclosed cockpit you feel the wind and
the speed it's really fun to drive very
sporty but quite a smooth ride it's very
quick and feels very positive thanks to
the four-wheel-drive he says and always
have enough power coming out of the bend
and the 430 horsepower engine gives a
plenty of oomph
klaus is now going to do a country road
test after all he says that's where most
people will be driving their target GTS
get this will tell the excitement
luckily there are some picturesque
country roads in southern Spain and what
could be better than to be travelling
along and a convertible when the weather
is fine the targa is also more
comfortable than most of the 911 series
and dynamic to boot
Klaus says the target is a really nice
convertible that's also suitable for
everyday use his conclusion this target
GTS is a perfect card both in terms of
performance on the racing track and for
taking it easy on country roads the 137
thousand euro price tag however does put
him off a bit and also means that the
pleasure will remain reserved for the
select few though feel a common mission
in the nose this out of here - Ellie so
lean back and enjoy you can always dream
that you're taking the target GTS out
for a spin
you